bonsoir nathalie a poussé là vous êtes
député la république en marche dans la
sixième circonscription des yvelines
alors le ministre d'intérieur christophe
castaner vous arrive
récemment confié avec la députée
catherine o som la mission d'élaborer un
plan d'action pour lutter contre la
recrudescence des rodéos urbains
quelles vont être vos pistes de travail
demain soir eh bien je crois que la loi
a donné les bases pour caractériser un
délit ces comportements dangereux et
maintenant il faut avoir une vision plus
globale on ne peut pas toujours procéder
à des flagrants délits et donc je pense
que c'est en lien avec les élus locaux
la police municipale et bien sûr police
nationale gendarmerie que nous pouvons
appréhender mieux le phénomène dans sa
globalité et je pense notamment au fait
de de renforcer la capacité d'anticiper
ces rodéos puisque comme je vous le
disais on ne peut pas toujours alger en
flagrant délit donc c'est en renforçant
leur enseignement aller coûte aussi des
quartiers de voir comment ça se passait
et peut-être de bien intégrer aussi les
associations qui suivent notamment le
jeune public donc le renseignement la
surveillance et renforcer les capacités
d'investigation pendant confinement les
rodéos urbains ont augmenté de 15% en
créant parfois des rassemblements
illégaux
comment agir face à ces grands groupes
oui alors la loi prévoit aussi de
pénaliser les instigateurs de tels
rassemblements et c'est vrai que là
c'est un phénomène nouveau
comme la route étaient désertés par les
usagers habituels qui étaient confinés
chez eux
et qui ne prenait plus les routes
certains se sont cru que voilà la route
était ouvert pour faire ce qu'on appelle
des run sur des routes nationales voire
sur des autoroutes ça c'est un
comportement qui cherchent à provoquer
et qui est complètement inacceptable
parce que éminemment dangereux pour tous
les autres usagers de la route et et qui
cherchent le contact avec les forces de
police
et ça ce n'est pas acceptable et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut par le renseignement
essayez de d'arrêter d'en de 2,2 oui de
que ces rodéos ne se produise avant
avant que le rassemblement ait pris son
départ
vous avez été rapporteur de la
proposition de loi en 2018
donc le rodéo urbain est devenu un délit
passible de deux ans de prison et 30
mille euros d'un monde
est ce que le plan d'action est il un
complément de cette loi oui c'est
exactement ça s'éteint c'est un
complément nous verrons s'il est
judicieux de renforcer la loi donc sur
telle ou telle plante sur tel aspect
nous verrons aussi si l'articulation
avec le judiciaire est adapté je pense
que c'est un point très important pour
que effectivement des tels comportements
soient réprimés et que l'on est un
véritable effet dissuasif à long terme
enfin il faut que les parquets pour que
la justice suive
faut-il renforcer selon vous la
surveillance et les sanctions dans
certaines villes du coup alors c'est pas
forcément ville par ville
mais je crois qu'il faut vraiment un un
maillage
sur nos territoires pour apprécier les
comportements les phénomènes qui s'y
déroulent dans nos villes ville par
ville
et pour arriver à les caractériser il
faut pouvoir faire la différence entre
si vous voulez des jeunes qui vont faire
un peu des bravades face à la police
dans un endroit assez je dirais
restreint un périmètre restreint de ceux
qui ont des motos super puissante qui
leur permettent d'acheminer des trafics
de drogue et qui qui n'ont absolument
plus peur de la police etc voilà il faut
quand même faire une distinction est
forcément adapté le niveau 2 de
sanctions en fonction des dj de la
situation et les contrevenants merci à
nathalie applaudi rêve d'avoir répondu à
nos questions on le rappelle vous êtes
débuté la république en marche dans les
yvelines et vous êtes donc en charge de
l'élaboration du plan d'action pour
lutter contre la recrudescence des
rodéos urbains
merci m